partisan politics are crippling
America's response to the corona virus
pandemic Chuck Schumer and Senate
Democrats blocking a critical stimulus
bill for a second time it would provide
over a trillion dollars of relief to
millions of workers and businesses
directly impacted by the outbreak it
comes as America's Surgeon General warns
that this is going to be a bad week for
the country infections are soaring in
America with over 40,000 cases and 500
dead Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell calling out Democrats for
prioritizing their wish list instead of
backing a clean stimulus bill here's
just some of the back-and-forth time for
Democrats to stop playing politics and
step up to the plate if the entire
economy continues to crumble here are
some of the items on the Democratic wish
list over which they choose over which
they choose to block this legislation
last night tax credits for solar energy
and wind energy provisions to force
employers to give special new treatment
to Big Labor and listen to this new
admission Sanders for the airlines are
you kidding me maybe the majority leader
thinks it's unfair to ask protections
for workers those are not extraneous
issues that is a wish list for workers
nobody else and over in the House Nancy
Pelosi - introducing her own stimulus
plan and instead of focusing on
immediate relief Pelosi is attacking
President Trump over Obamacare I'm
calling on President Trump to abandon
his lawsuit seeking to strike down the
Affordable Care Act instead the
president should urge the 14 states who
have refused to expand Medicaid to do so
today House Democrats are unveiling that
take responsibility for workers and
Families Act a bill that takes
responsibility for the health wages and
well-being of America's workers okay
mister Gutfeld I think everybody knows
the relief package isn't gonna be
perfect I'd like to see a little bit
more
in there for workers maybe twice as much
for families but I don't see anything
wrong with having strings attached for
you know no stock buybacks no bonuses
but for attaching strings to things like
making sure there is more women on
corporate boards or new green New Deal
issues that's fine but that's not what
this is about you know there are two
things one to your point does it have to
be perfect we're not in a time of luxury
where you can hone this package to an
ideal thing you know when a firefighter
is facing a blaze does he stop and go
hey excuse me is that mineral or tap
water no he gets that hose and he points
it at the fire this package this relief
package is the hose the water that we
need but the bigger problem though is
that note I consider myself a lay person
I have no idea what's wrong with this
bill ideological language obscures the
truth so that the lay people cannot see
what's going on so it's like we need a
visual model to show us what these bones
of contention are what are the
absurdities and what aren't the
absurdities a chart a graph a doll where
you could say this is where they
disagree this is where they don't but
instead you know we just see how
politics undermines everything I mean
oddly politics is the invisible virus
that's gonna beat us it's not going to
be the coronavirus because if this keeps
us from getting the stimulus or the
relief package for the economy then
we're all screwed so it's if you know
what we are asked as as Americans to
sacrifice we're told to stay in our
homes and not go to work then they
should do their effin job they should be
stopped playing this stupid game and
match our sacrifice or else they'd
forgotten us as citizens it is amazing
one how the whole country can come
together except politicians in
Washington DC well I mean in fairness to
the politicians Jesse keep in mind this
would be the third phase they've already
passed one bill they put money more
money into the federal government's
healthcare response all the federal
agencies that deal with healthcare and
then secondly pass some money to help
with unemployment to help with paid
leave and even in some cases to help
people with their healthcare cost so
this is a step that's meant in terms of
the larger economy and in that regard
the key to my mind is that they should
be very careful here because what we
want is to put more money in people's
pockets because consumer spending is the
key to our economic recovery down the
road so you want people to be able to
pay their bills right they're unemployed
or whatever that they don't stop paying
their bills instead what the Democrats
see and I just want to offer you that
perspective is they see are like a four
hundred and twenty five billion dollar
amount of money that's being given to
the Federal Reserve that the incumbent
administration Trump administration the
Federal Reserve can decide who gets that
money who doesn't get that money
Congress would have very little or no
oversight and they're worried it just
becomes what they're calling here a
slush fund for big business and they
want to make sure that unlike 2008 when
a lot of people said afterwards oh my
gosh this was too big to fail we bailed
out Wall Street again you know Joe
Manchin today the Senate from West
Virginia he was on the floor arguing
with Mitch McConnell the Senate Majority
Leader said you know we don't have masks
in West Virginia we don't have gowns we
don't have ventilators that's what
should be here rather than your focus on
Wall Street
ya dig and I understand some criticism
you don't want a so-called bailout again
and it's not the fault of these
industries that they didn't cause this
recession you're just kind of giving
them liquidity so then they can keep
employees instead of firing them or give
them access to capital in terms of loans
so small businesses can stay afloat this
isn't just Wall Street this is far from
it these are the companies that all
Americans work for this is a large swath
of the US economy that has basically
been put out of business overnight they
are suffering no fault of their own
just like individuals just like the
people who've been laid off the millions
of people who've been laid off and to
correct one that four hundred twenty
five billion dollars goes to the
Treasury and acts as a backstop for
lending at the Federal Reserve which
would total about four trillion dollars
that's how you
leverage that amount of money that's why
this is critical so while Congress is
flailing and failing the American people
and dithering and bickering
it's the Nerds over at the Fed that
stepped up today with a whatever it
takes to rescue this economy we are
going all in to lending facilities to
make sure corporations aren't insolvent
you know what happens if large
corporations in this country and solve
it we're talking about the Great
Depression for the next decade so leave
it to the Federal Reserve oh and by the
way just really quickly the Fed is also
planning to roll out a Main Street
business lending program that will
support lending to small and mid-sized
businesses but they need help from
Congress to backstop that so where are
we
we're staring into the abyss because of
those losers in Congress yeah and then
it looks like they had somewhat of a
deal at some point over the weekend and
then Nancy Pelosi flies in from
California and throws the whole thing
kind of haywire what what do you think
she was calculating here well I think
it's it's a pretty stark situation when
Mitch McConnell would probably rather be
working with Harry Reid than Chuck
Schumer at this moment because as you
know we might remember they did not get
along so well but at least Harry Reid
would not have been pushed around by the
Speaker of the House yeah if you think
about what happened last weekend Mitch
McConnell took all sorts of ridiculous
accusations of him not working through
the weekend the thing is there wasn't a
bill that the house had passed for them
to work on over the weekend and instead
what you have is them holding things up
making the stock market go down even
further and again to it to Diggins point
and the president said this from the
beginning this is not the fault of the
workers they did nothing wrong these are
these are not people that weren't paying
their mortgages or if you like with the
Wall Street banks situation that this is
nothing like that and the country needs
to step up big and fast and it's not
going to be perfect now remember it with
Wall Street those banks paid back the
money pretty quickly because the economy
got back up and running
we need the
to be back up and running quickly and
they need to do it big I think that
they'll probably get it done by midnight
tonight wow that would be fantastic
just in time for the market there might
be a procedural reason that the
Democrats have might have screwed this
up so much that they can't vote until
Wednesday procedurally but I know that
they're trying to do it fast
all right well we'll be covering it here
and keeping you guys posted